it's like I'm hypnotized by it we're at
BuzzFeed and today we're making pumpkin
pasties which are pretty delicious so
this is pumpkin looks like this is brown
sugar coming in here you know you would
wave the wand and you would just fall in
this with stir but it's like you're
still participate I'll see there I go it
works well those words let's add this
other stuff boom uh yeah okay so that's
oh wait so that's gingers Wow oh well
there you go so I had to patronesses um
I had a white stallion and a black
stallion and apparently that's really
rare that you get the same sort of
animal I'm like I got two sides of the
same coin which I thought was very I got
the greatest world which is what I'm
wearing this hat and and then it says
nuts at the top so that we do is we take
this and we we mark what it means right
now we have to wait and moisten the
edges well we're gonna do that we're
gonna put this guy in first we're gonna
put some of the mixture
hey good but look look at oh this is
gonna be delicious and you should go
with this so what would be a cooking
spell what could I use what can I say as
a cooking's bro-down mix of spells um
after your potato kanishka wait a minute
how did I do that oh my god magic oh my
god can we clean 3ty excuse me well I'm
rich I told you